hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update amazon finally confirmed
their set-top box competitor the amazon
fire TV and it's available today for
ninety nine dollars the Amazon fire TV
was announced today at a media event in
New York it'll have games from EA Disney
and Sega and there will also be a
version of Minecraft available the
device features a quad-core
best-in-class processor with a dedicated
GPU as well as two gigs of RAM amazon
promises two times the performance of
competitors like Apple TV Roku and
chromecast and the Amazon fire TV will
also ship with a Bluetooth controller
that has a microphone in it for voice
control amazon is also making games
itself internally the first of which is
a third-person shooter called 70 which
will presumably be an amazon exclusive
the system is priced at $99 for the base
model but stand-alone controllers cost
forty dollars there's no discount for a
bundle though amazon fire TV with a
controller still costs you guessed it
one hundred forty dollars the Amazon
fire TV is not being marketed as a
console competitor but is instead aimed
at gamers who primarily play on
smartphones and tablets the system will
also come with 1,000 amazon coins for
purchasing games though it's unclear
what that represents in real world
currency will be getting a console in
the office hopefully really soon so stay
tuned to gamespot com for even more info
about the Amazon fire TV